We all have an internal dialogue within our minds - to remind yourself to drive your mobile phone
Bill, or even the exercise is a difficult conversation with a friend. But what if this sound becomes
Sounds that are out of your control?
Psychologist Julian Jaynes suggested that not all human voices should be heard
- internally created from the right hemisphere of the brain, but seen as external from the
In the left hemisphere (of the bilateral legislative system). As a result these sounds were seen as contacts
Of the gods. But around 1000 BC BC, with the rise of modern consciousness, these sounds
It is recognized as our own. Some psychiatrists believe that the brains of people schizophrenia
May return to this state, and some of their ideas are recognized as their property.
Schizophrenia is a disease that affects the nervous system, affecting approximately 1% of the
population. To be clear, schizophrenia is not the same as "multiple personality
disturbance'. Symptoms of hallucinations often include: seeing things that are not there, to
Illusions such as high belief in the plot, high rates of depression, the most prominent
Hear voices. Hearing hallucinations occur in many disorders - from simple sounds to
Words or names that are called - but sounds heard in schizophrenic patients are quite different.
Often they are associated with the current psychological state, and can be very hostile, accusing,
Threat or persecution (58); ultimately embody many of their fears.
A 2006 study found more than 3,000 schizophrenic patients that genes related to immune function
May play a role - specifically a complement of 4 or C4 genes. C4 is a gene concerned
In pruning the synapses in the brain. For example, teen minds undergo a process
Known as 'synaptic pruning' in which unused connections are cut off to help our brains
efficiency. But in individuals with schizophrenia, this C4 gene may be excessive and cut off
Areas that participate in planning, perception and thinking. The links are also made between
Microbes in the intestines - after all, microbes that have lived within us have also emerged
The immune response and development modify the brain's effect. One study found that lactic acid
Bacteria have been significantly more abundant in people with schizophrenia, while another
Found that the prevalence of fat and glucose abnormalities is significantly higher in patients with
Schizophrenia.
Although schizophrenia is diagnosed and is based primarily on behavior and reported experiences,
Research has found the cause to be a combination of these genetic factors with some environmental
Stressors such as growing up in an urban area, minority position, and even cannabis
THC has also been used to exaggerate a psychological response in some individuals with genetic or developmental risks
Shock .
Currently, a medicine for schizophrenia focuses mostly on the fight against hallucinations and delusions
Unfortunately, 49.5% of patients with schizophrenia do not end up taking medication for them.
This is why genetic research is so important to fight this disease. Of course, some
People can not recover through a combination of medications, advice and support that
It can greatly reduce symptoms.
On AsapTHOUGHT we talk about how a stain on mental health is a serious issue in our culture and
The media. Many of us contribute negatively to the stereotype of mental illness without
So achieve it - so we break 5 ways that we all can reduce the mental health stigma right
right Now. Check it out with the link below.
And special thanks for audio audible to support this episode to give you a free trial version for 30 days
At audible.com/asap. This week we wanted to recommend the book "Schizophrenia: Understanding
Symptoms Diagnosis and Treatment "which addresses much of the stigma associated with schizophrenia
How affects those who have a condition. You can get a free 30-day trial at audible.com/asap
The choice of a wide range! We love them because they are great when you're on
Go.
And subscribe to get more science weekly videos!